angry frustrated and desperate sri
lankan surrounded the president's office
in colombo
fed up having to queue for food medicine
cooking gas and vehicle fuel paying 30
to 60 percent more for many items
millions are struggling to make ends
meet and blame president gotaber
rajapaksa and the government
[Music]
must be chased out that's what this
river of people wants
in time to come people all will come to
come to uh to the ground to the roads
and they will protest this government to
chase out immediately the opposition
sama gi jana balavega organized the
latest protest following weeks of
similar demonstrations around the
country
the sjb is challenging the president to
turn things around or step down
are you ready to send this government
home is the country ready to send it
home friends with this great people's
power we will begin the journey to chase
out this government
sri lanka has had a worsening economy
for the past three years
the 2019 easter bomb attacks on churches
and hotels killed 270 people and hit
vital tourism revenue the pandemic which
followed further hampered recovery
analysts blame unsustainable debt low
revenue a foreign exchange crisis
financial mismanagement and corruption
for aggravating dire problems we are
sick of this government because we are
suffering
you know the children
they have no milk they have this nothing
while they are enjoying their life
sri lanka's foreign reserves have fallen
to their lowest levels in recent history
fuel has run out to keep a steady supply
of electricity and the government
doesn't have money to pay for vital
imports
after months of rejecting calls to seek
an international bailout the government
appears ready to seek help for months
sri lankans have complained about
shortages and price increases but things
have got so bad now they say they don't
have a choice but to take to the streets
professionals executives farmers
fishermen housewives and day wage
earners all hoping their voices will be
heard
fernandez al jazeera colombo